c'était une journée en soutien au projet
mosaïque roule contre le cancer
l'association mosaïque centre social à
et kevin se lance pour la troisième
édition dans un défi à vélo du 25 au 30
octobre cette année laventure par des
sables d'olonne pour se terminer dans la
ligne bis noise music roll contre le
cancer ça vu jours suite à une
initiative de jeunes en 2018 suite au
décès de leur camarade et se sont
mobilisés entre guillemets on n'a rien
pu faire pour notre camarade qui est
décédé comment peut accompagner ou
soutenir les autres les jeunes ont donc
établi un parcours pour sensibiliser la
population dans d'autres villes comme
nantes angers ou le mans on va s'arrêter
dans différentes villes donc en tout cas
je croyais à cette ville dans chaque
ville où on s'arrête on va rencontrer
des jeunes on va sensibiliser le conseil
si vous participez à ce projet parce que
c'est ta une façon de lutter contre une
bonne cause et
balas et cancer et c'est quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur et pour faire
connaître ce projet osé quevillois des
ateliers étaient organisés comme un
atelier réparation un atelier vélo
smoothie ou encore une balade parents
enfants à vélo
l'objectif de cette journée est double
le premier ça va être de sensibiliser à
tout ce qui va être la sécurité routière
de transport en vélo et inciter des gens
à faire du vélo est deuxième à une cause
qui est noble qu'est le cancer et donc
on en revient à miser gros le contre le
cancer dont vraiment sensibiliser la
population à ce que c'est le cancer
pendant six jours douze jeunes dès que
vie vont parcourir 600 km une cagnotte
li ti a été ouverte pour soutenir le
projet